Il s'agit ici d'une expérimentation sur un site qui a été fouillé à Baie au 2e semestre 2009.
C'est la fouille d'un grand domaine rural antique qui était installé à l'emplacement où on a construit un lotissement aujourd'hui.
Alors en premier lieu, on y rencontre la résidence proprement dite du maître de l'exploitation agricole.
C'est une grande exploitation agricole avec une partie résidentielle dans laquelle on trouve une grande demeure.
Une salle de réunion dans laquelle le maître des lieux recevait sa clientelle
Il y a également un petit sanctuaire privé
Et puis il y a juste à côté la maison du gérant du domaine.
Et donc à l'extérieur on a des granges.
Et on a un petit sanctuaire.
L'expérimentation se fait dans une salle où on a plusieurs écrans.
Plusieurs projecteurs.
Et donc, des lunettes avec des capteurs
qui nous permettent de voyager
dans le domaine
de mieux nous rendre compte
de la physionomie des installations
et également surtout de valider les hypothèses de restitutions qui ont été proposées
à l'issu de la fouille
et aussi cela nous montre que dans l'interprétation des vestiges
on ne s'est pas trompé
on a pas d'incohérence majeure
Cet outil peut-être utilisé pour d'autres sites
On pourrait imaginer, si on avait suffisamment de données, une promenade dans un quartier de la ville antique de Condate (Rennes)